au théâtre montparnasse et dans une
pièce de noel coward les amants
terribles écrite en 1934 que deux
enfants terribles de cinéma font leur
rentrée le thème mais l'amour c'est
évident tout le monde aura pu deviner
une pièce sur le bonheur de noël coward
comme vous savez elle est jouée par
danielle darrieux jean claude pascal
agathe d'attention françois guérin et
jenny alpha et noel coward l'avait
écrite pour une grande amie à lui des
retraites laurence parce qu'ils avaient
envie de jouer une très longue scène
d'amour ne pas faire une banque saine
d'amour il a donc fait des variations
sur le mariage et le divorce avec toutes
les facéties dont ils étaient capables
les deux protagonistes ont été mariée à
l'acteur 0 et ils ont divorcé à l'apd 0
et au premier atelier pièce il se
retrouve tout à fait par hasard sur deux
terrasses continue pendant le rituel
voyage de ness
cet orchestre les attend notamment
pouvais pas
je souffre mon voyage de noces votre
rencontre avec les amants terribles
parce que ça a été une bonne rencontre
au point de vue du texte et du
personnage est ce que c'est un rayonnage
personnages merveilleux à jouer parce
qu' il est plusieurs femmes en une enfin
ce n'est pas nous n'a pas une seule
ligne et elle est farfelu les folles les
profondes les féminines et payer un peu
de tout aussi bon
moitié moi tu sais oui il vous plaît que
je viendrais te mon sens son café du
matin
je demande toute la journée c'est un
problème de conséquence on essaie qui né
d'une longue méditation guitare du sucre
en civil et armés
vous avez suivi naturellement je vous
appellerai et mendy comme c'est émouvant
mais s'ils m'ont dit qu'elles résistent
et bien si maman entre ne se ressent pas
trop de la séance d'hier au soir les 10
euros car je suis à savoir alarmante que
je prendrais volontiers une tasse de
café au lait merci à
croisant pardon à l'onu - mais si oui
merci 320 sucre beurre et confiture
c'est à dire anglaise c'est un gars qui
est capable de faire changer comme ça
toute sa vie en un clin d'oeil et sans
faire d'éclat souvent alors qu'elle est
plus accessible si vous voulez elle est
plus accessible
voilà alors c est une pièce complètement
joyeuse décontracté ironique où j'espère
qu'on rit beaucoup et dont on sort je
l'espère comme d'un film de lou beats ou
de caprins heureux